one of the stars in the women's game
tatev abrahamian played
kind of conservative chess with knight
f3 and d4 but now it seems like you've
gone back to your slash and burn style
with e4 she gave you the kind of
position that you revel in i mean i just
got everything i could have wanted out
of the opening just had no play all my
pieces are on good squares or king it's
not going anywhere during sicilian what
made you decide to go back to e4 in this
game
um the more water that she plays is not
very good and like i was looking at it
in g4 it's pretty problematic and
she's not the kind of player who like
likes to get like she doesn't play the
kind of sicilian where she gets directly
attacked so she kind of left her king in
the center but then it doesn't really
work out well in this line
were you surprised when she gave you a
piece
yeah i thought she would go knight v6 i
was kind of thinking about it because i
think even the end game is good for me
but she played so quickly and um i mean
i knew this doesn't work out but i was
just kind of surprised i was not
expecting it and she was playing so fast
too so i was wondering um
like what like what
where did she think she went wrong or
like what what was going through her
mind
uh yeah this just turned into a straight
beatdown when she was down a piece
clearly a resignation would have been at
any point in this position
you started off the tournament poorly
you've come back though bounced back
with some wins particularly with white
it looks like did you win all your games
this is the second game on this
tournament really i felt like you won
three games with white for some reason
this is only your second because you're
thinking of my game maybe against that
street that i was winning but i didn't
win oh that's right no no this is my
second win of the tournament second win
of the tournament uh
there's only two more rounds to go your
your feel about this tournament it's not
positive
not positive
not a good question to ask you still
have you know fighting chances to at
least get get a good good score back are
you 50 now or still minus one i'm at
minus one minus one okay well
you got two rounds left uh who do you
play do you know uh i have wide against
megan tomorrow and then i finished black
against crash so it's a tough finish but
against crush yeah i have vlogging wow
that's a big big actually two two of the
players you could affect the destiny of
this tournament yeah because she might
might be in a must-win situation so she
might have to take some risks i don't
know and your your feel about uh
potentially being a spoiler in the
tournament does that matter to you at
all of course
when you're having a bad term and that's
like your only job then to spoil someone
else's
okay we like that attitude we'll leave
it there thanks for joining us congrats
on your game
congratulations tata
speaking of the game i